Great.
You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio, several
U. C. N. N. P. R. Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad hand.
I'm Robert Krulwich and this is not the regular radio lab new.
Now this is radio lab. The podcast meaning you'd like to explain? Yes,
it's radio lab, even between our regular season shows.
So this is going to be a little shorter probably than the regular shows and a
little less produced, but a lot of fun because it's birthday time.
I'm Hanna to say happy birthday of course to Charles.
Do I want to chuck down when is sometimes like that more air Charles Darwin
Brown. Just be quiet and listen to me for just a second.
I want to say that a lot of people, when they think about Charles Darwin,
think about a brilliant, brilliant man who 150 or so years ago,
woke up some morning and thought, wow,
I have a wonderful deep insight into the nature of how life changed. Well,
it was wonderful. It was deep. It's one of the deep whatever. Yes.
But it wasn't instant.
And that's the first thing we ought to say about Charles Darwin is that he did
not have an Excelsior idea.
He had a notion which gradually formed into an idea,
which then required an enormous amount of hard,
hard work. And to begin,
I'd like to play you a story I did a number of years ago with David Coleman,
who was one of the best scholars about Darwin that I know,
he's actually a professional journalist, but we call him a scholar
and you're suddenly living in a world where our scholars and journalists are on
par by not, you know, cause cause, cause David works very hard,
but he doesn't even work as close to hard as chuck doe.
And as I like to call him. So let's listen to this story,
which is Darwin working out of theory.
[inaudible]
150 years ago when people asked,
how come you can go to Australia and there are kangaroos hopping,
hopping around everywhere.
But you go to places that look almost exactly the same, say, um,
grasslands in Africa and there are no kangaroos. Now, why is that?
Why not the same kinds of places have the same kinds of animals? Well,
150 years ago there was an answer was a simple one. So the science writer,
David Coleman, God has made Kangaroos and put them in Australia. So God did it.
He decided that was what God wanted to do.
God created every species individually and put them down wherever they are.
I actually, I call that special creation plus special delivery.
So that was the explanation even among some of the most learned people around,
but then says Kwaman Darwin came along and said, wait a minute.
I don't think that's the explanation.
I think these things all evolved from common ancestors.
So the reason you find Kangaroos only in Australia and New Guinea, he said,
it's not God's doing.
It's because the earliest kangaroo ancestors evolve there and then they spread
out by, they couldn't get across the water that surrounds Australia.
They went 'em out as far as they could go. Every plant,
every animal that you see Darwin proposed got where it is today on its own.
Animals and plants must disperse.
They must be capable of dispersing in order to explain what we see on the planet
by way of evolution.
So it was critical to Darwin's theory to show how living things got to where
they are today. And this can get kind of tricky. For example, a cabbages.
You can find cabbage plants on islands near Antarctica.
Now how would a cabbage get there? Well,
either God put it there or it got there on its own. Yeah,
but how does a cabbage seed cross an ocean on its own? Yeah. Cow. Well,
it turns out the Darwin obsessed about this question,
vegetable voyaging for years,
he concocted experiments and experiments that were so delightful.
And so unlike what you'd imagined. Exactly, exactly.
You remember the old TV show watch Mr Wizard? That was Darwin.
That was Charles Darwin. Here's a perfect example. Darwin wondered,
how might a radish
travel? Well,
he imagined that a radish might accidentally get swept to see on a windy day.
But now the questions do radishes float. Well, Darwin had his bucked,
Mr Parsippany for salt water and like oceans into a tub
and into that tub they flopped radishes and carrots.
And Rhubarb and celery and Mr Parslow was,
he was one of these proper English butlers. Absolutely. Yeah.
I guess there weren't too many other butlers in the vicinity who have come to do
this sort of thing. Probably not know Bob. Mr Postel also dropped in seeds.
He tried cabbage seeds, radish seeds, pepper, um,
cress as in watercress.
And then they watched to see what floated for how long.
Then they'd removed the wet seeds and they plant them to see if they would still
grow. Some do better than others. With radish seeds,
he got 42 days worth of floating and with Cres, uh,
42 days plus a wonderful quantity of mucus, Darwin said,
if I recall correctly. So it's stinky, but it's sly,
a slimy mess that still travels the ocean. And that's typical of Darwin,
that he would not say a, you know, a disgusting or a gross quantity of mucus.
He would say a wonderful quantity of mucous because everything about the natural
world was wondrous to this guy. Okay. So that's 42 days for the radish,
42 days for the crest. How much now for dried asparagus seed,
85 days,
they stayed afloat 85 days and then he took him out and planted the seeds and
they germinated. So let's do the math. I winded.
If an asparagus seed can float for eating five continuous days and an ocean
current moves roughly 38 miles a day, let's 85
times 38 that means an asparagus can sale 3,230 miles across the sea.
That's,
that's like Magella asparagus is key at least among those Darwin with them.
Yeah. So yes, ocean crossing vegetables are possible,
but Darwin didn't stop there.
One day his eight year old son Francis said to him, you know,
dad did birds float, Kinda like ships. And his father said, yeah,
he seems to have been a terrific father. So Francis said, well,
why don't we feed a birds some seeds so the seeds get inside the bird and then
you know, shoot the bird and then a lot, but in a tub,
the corpse and let it float for awhile. So he suggested that and Darwin said,
you Bet Francis, that's a great idea. Then after a month or whatever,
they open up the dead carcass and they pulled out the seeds inside and they
planted them and found that those seeds also germinated,
thereby establishing the principle that seeds can either float on their own or
they can hitch a ride as passengers inside a bird as passengers attached to the
foot of a bird, which then led Darwin back to animals.
And to the last science article he ever published,
in which he proposed the possibility of flying clams.
Now at this point, Darwin wasn't so well,
he's suffering from degenerative heart disease, but he's still working.
He's still very much alive mentally.
And one day he gets a letter from a shoe salesman,
a young guy named Walter Crick. And the way the story goes,
you imagine crick out in the woods collecting beef.
Look what he just happened to see. It was a water beetle.
And when he got down and you look close and attached to one of the legs was a
little clam, a little freshwater clam, and very,
very little small enough that the beetles scarcely noticed it and quick truck.
That's kind of curious. So he wrote down and he said, you know,
I think you might be interested in this, and sure enough,
Darwin wrote right back and he asked him all kinds of questions that crick
couldn't answer because after all he was, he was in the shoe business,
so he did something better than you know, fake it.
He sent the beetle with the shell attached to Darwin.
He mailed it and he just popped it into an envelope.
He popped it into an envelope. Was the,
was the clam still attached to the needle? It was. It was. So he said, okay,
well you take a look for yourself. Yeah. So a day or two later,
the beetle and the clam did arrive at Darwin's house in an envelope,
but they were separated now and the beetle,
the beetle was dying by the time that he got clean.
Very wasn't feeling very well,
but right away Darwin could see a possibility here. This is very interesting.
This goes back to the whole subject of dispersal of how creatures can travel
from one place to another. Maybe this little clamp can fly from a hot place,
right? Because this beetle is a swimming beetle, but it can also fly.
So maybe clams can fly from pond to pond hitchhiking on a beetle.
Darwin couldn't prove this because he felt kind of badly watching that little
beetle he had suffer.
So this is why I mentioned it at the end of my book because it's such a
wonderful example of the kind of fellow this Guy Charles Darwin was,
he writes back to wd crick and says, dear Mr Crick,
as the wretched beetle is still feebly alive, he wrote,
I put it in a bottle with chopped Laurel leaves.
Now he knew that those leaves give off a gas that would very gently help this
beetle die. And one of the very last acts of his life,
he decided that he needed to put this beetle out of its misery.
And then a few weeks after that, uh, Darwin died himself.
There is a postscript to this story. It turns out that years and years later,
the shoe salesman, Walter Crick,
had some grandchildren and one of Walter's grandsons just happens to be Francis
Crick. The code is the Francis,
the Francis Crick co-discoverer of the structure of DNA with James Watson.
So perhaps the greatest champion of evolution in the 20th century who deciphered
the structure and the code of DNA. Both that guy's Grandpa,
his grandpa was a pen Powell sharing beetle specimens with Darwin.
And how strange and wonderful is that
and it is kind of strange [inaudible] you ended the piece with how strange ended
the piece that way, but the,
that it's very strange you who always sweat the ending and torture me on the
endings you ended with. How strange is that? Well, here's why.
Because think about science the way it's done today. Yeah.
You have to finish high school, you have to get good grades,
you have to take the sats, you have to get into college,
you have to be a major in science.
Then you should go to the and get the cherries or the public as a white.
But then the very specialized now and look at that, look at their science.
This is Charles Darwin with the Butler and the tubs.
I like that part of it's very optimistic in a way, and very homespun, you know,
here's what I don't get. Um,
he comes up with this idea in like 1830 something, right? Yes. He's,
he's a young man. When he, when he,
when he figures out maybe species evolve in this peculiar, right?
So he's got the idea in 1838 and he's a young dude,
and then it's only like 20 something years later when he finally 21,
one 21 years later that he finally actually comes out with it and publishes it
in here. What happened in the gap was he testing? That's one of the,
that's one of the great questions is why did Charles Darwin wait so long to
announce the idea?
One version of that is that he just wanted to do what you just heard him do.
He wanted to be sure you had a test and evidence, evidence story.
The other reason is actually a more romantic and interesting and also sad reason
because it tells you that from the beginning,
this idea had deep problems with its audience. In this case,
Charles Darwin's audience was a precious audience.
It was the woman he fell in love with. Um, what's her name?
I don't think I should tell you because think you're going to learn it from
Deborah Highly Gwinn who is an author of a new book called Charles and
[inaudible] Emma. Anyway,
Deborah wish that that was be, we were talking [inaudible] and she tells me, uh,
let's see. Let's go back to when Charles was in his mid twenties. Here we go.
Okay, I'm 28. I've got this promising career, this,
this great theory I'm thinking about now. He goes today,
cause next big decision, should he get married or not right to what does he do?
Well, he makes a list of pros and cons.
Is it called pro marriage or con? Met with,
it's called marry. Not Marry. This is the question.
Let's hear the, let's hear the knock Mary things. Uh,
fighting with her like that would, that would, that would could be a problem.
Yes. Um, and he, he did, he, you know,
he loved children and so he really thought about having children but,
but he also worried about again the time it would take to raise children and the
expense and also the anxiety.
Meanwhile what was on the pro side if I do Mary, what did you get?
He was looking for somebody who would sit on the sofa with him and you know,
make nice and you know, whatever. Um,
but I think when he made that a of game,
yes. Right. Cause they did pay but did they play? They played,
Charles and Emma played backgammon and now we gave away that it was Emma.
So there they are. We're wondering which way to glide.
There's one big question that he did not put on his list. God,
why God,
he really was beginning to think that he was having problems with God and with
religion in general.
And he knew very often that if the man was a skeptic or religious skeptic and
the woman was a believer, things went along fine until there was some problem.
Somebody got sick, somebody died,
and then the woman was miserable because the husband wasn't a believer.
And if the husband is in the believer Jad,
then that person's probably going to go to hell for not having faith in God.
So when you go onto your returnal arrest,
you're in hell and your life is in heaven.
And so that's a long time to be apart.
So you want to stay with them here and there. Yeah.
Darwin falls in love as it happens with one of these religious girls.
Emma April's really in love with her, but she says to him, Oh, I don't know,
I want to live with you forever in heaven. And she's a believer. Yeah.
So during their courtship, they talk about this,
he shares his doubts about the existence of God.
She says her hope that he will come out, come to faith,
but she does agree to marry him in spite of that.
And um, she, you know, when he's there,
she's all happy cause he's so Charles and she loves him and he's great.
And then he goes away. I can still relate to this.
And then she starts to worry because he's not there to sort of distract her with
his wonderfulness. She worries about his not having faith,
um, or losing his faith. I mean,
to me it's never clear exactly what he's thinking exactly. I mean,
I don't think it was clear to him he was struggling with it,
let's put it that way. Right.
She probably knew she wasn't going to really change his mind,
but she just knew that prayer was really helpful to her and she saw him in pain
and emotional pain and, and she thought if he would just pray,
maybe he would feel better, but she didn't want to really say that to him.
So she wrote it down and said, sometimes it's easier to write something down.
And she wrote him I think a three letters during their time together maybe for,
um, he kept those letters with him all the time. Um,
and he, and he wrote,
he knew he just had a feeling he would die first and he wanted her to know after
he was gone that he really took our concerns seriously.
He also on the,
on the letter itself wrote some later point right when I'm dead,
no, that many times I have kissed and cried over this
[inaudible]
so they were, they were, they had an arrangement? No,
he grieved for her. She grieved for him. And they were,
they had very different ideas about what death meant until something happened in
their lives. That I, it's, it's,
it has a kind of a feeling of real deep tragedy about it.
What, um, whose Annie Annie was,
I'm their second child, their oldest daughter, and, um,
really the apple of their eye. She was, uh, a wonderful little girl. And,
um, Charles Darwin later said she was his favorite,
which I always have mixed feelings about because I don't think a parent should
have favorites, but there you go. Do you know why she was his favorite? Um,
she was spirited. She was kind, she was musical like Emma,
but she was orderly. Like Charles.
Emma was a slob and he was very attentive and connected to both of her parents.
But some scarlet fever had run through the household. It seemed in retrospect,
like Annie never got quite better
[inaudible]
after about a week of that right around Easter by the way. Um,
and it just got worse and worse and she finally died.
He and Emma said to each other and letters, right then we just have to be,
stay close to each other. Emma wrote to him, you are my prime treasurer.
And always have,
cause this was one of those moments where for a lot of couples you,
you can kind of go [inaudible]
considering what death meant to each of them and how different it is,
you know, the different meanings I took.
It's pretty amazing to me that I think it brought them even even closer.
[inaudible] the sense of along the way is that the reason that Charles Darwin
hung onto his idea and didn't,
one of the reasons is that he was worried that Emma would have been upset and
there's a reason right.
For him to feel that way because she's so much more or less intimated that
well, the thing that's great about Emma was that, um, you asked me before,
I think what, how they changed after Annie Staff.
I think they became a little bit more,
I think s they saw each other's point of view just a little bit more. I think.
I think Charles saw, oh,
would be probably really nice if I believed in it after life.
Cause then I could see Annie again and that would be lovely. And,
and I think probably as Emma Watch Charles working and, and, and probably, uh,
she struggled with what was the sense of Annie's staff? You know,
maybe there was no sense. Maybe it was just one of those things that happens.
I believe that they actually started to come together more than go apart in the
way they were thinking. Neither surrendered their poor, neither surrendered.
But I think that they were really able to see the other person's point of view,
which is really what all we need. Right. And so Emma,
who was never much interested in science by the way. Um,
but she was always his first reader and his best reader.
So whenever he was sending something out for publication,
she always read it back in, um, 1842,
he had first shown her and her alone this, um,
this sketch of his species theories just in case he should die.
And he said he wrote her a letter saying, in case I should die,
I'm trusting you to publish this. Well, you know,
she was the one who was so worried he was killing God and yet he trusted her and
he knew he could trust her.
And so Emma read it and manuscript and she didn't object to anything.
She didn't object to anything that would, um, you know,
maybe have sort of personally offended her about God. In fact,
she cleaned it up.
[inaudible]
cleaned up his language because he wasn't good with commas and you know,
and he had spelling mistakes and so she cleaned it up and made his arguments
stronger for him.
[inaudible]
so, wow. So emotionally she traveled a great distance. We did.
But here's my question.
If he can do so much work to convince the scientists, his colleagues,
that this is a theory that is true.
[inaudible]
and if he can, you know,
through a sort of personal loss and time and understanding,
convinced his wife through love really did. It's true.
Why can't he convince the rest of us?
I mean Ike [inaudible] our producer here too, I write just handed me paper,
which says that there was a Gallup poll of 1,018 Americans less than four out of
10 say they quote believe in the theory of, of evolution. That's less than 40%.
Yeah,
it's been that way by the way. For, for decades. You know, for decades he,
Darwin has never had a majority. No. So why? Well,
there are probably two simple reasons.
One is that people don't like thinking of themselves as beasts or animals.
And Darwin insisted. He always insisted.
We are not closer to the angels. We are not separate. We are not different.
We are beasts. We couldn't, you at least say to sort of counter that argument,
okay, we're beasts, but we're turbocharged beasts were like special beasts.
Say that. But that's not the only problem. There's what's number two?
The second one I think has to do with everybody's desire for, well,
let me just introduce you to Adam Gopnik who written another book about Charles
Town. He's, he's written more than no,
another one in our series of mini books that you're visiting here,
who you have the common book.
We have the Hollywood book and we know of the Gopnik book,
but I sat down with Adam and I,
we talked about what is the problem really with Darwin's theory.
Nope. Nobody understood and the 19th century better than Charles Darwin,
that death is the great reaper out of life.
He didn't believe in mortality and he believed in what he called the wedge of
death. He understood that that's how species proceed.
That's the nature of life is to involve a great deal of death.
But that realization of course provided him absolutely no comfort for the loss
of his own child.
Knowledge about the common experience gave him no ease in his core experience.
And that I think Robert is the deepest reason why we have trouble with Darwin in
some because we look to big ideas to take common experience and give us comfort
about our core experience. And no matter how we try and pull it apart,
no matter how we try and search it, Darwin is a mote do that for us.
We can't say, um,
I read Darwin and now I feel better about my own life.
Cause actually it makes you feel kind of worse because if you ask how did I get
here, there's a explanation in Darwin's rating for that.
But if you asked the one, everybody asked if he goes, why, what's it for?
How does it end? What's the point?
Then the answers are very unsatisfying.
One is don't know or don't speak to that or there is none or,
and this is not, that's hard. There is none. It's very hard for people to take.
I think too that it's, uh, you know, I,
I do think that there is a tragic grand jury in Darwin's view of life.
But it doesn't make me feel sad.
It makes me feel there is meaning there to be had. Darwin's love.
Charles, his love for Emma, Charles, his love for it,
and he still speak to us a hundred years later, we're moved by them. We're,
we're stirred by them.
We see pictures of our own life and our own loves in them.
Human life isn't meaningless because it ends.
And one of the great changes in human spirit that Darwin ushers in Darwin,
Harold's is a belief that the future is as important as our past and that our
real afterlife lies in our children and in the afterlife of our ideas and values
more than it lies in the inheritance of our ancestors and then now as part of a
river. Hmm. Yes.
That we're in a long river of time along wherever of life. And after, you know,
it's one of the things we try and teach our children. Like what?
When we talk about giving our kids a moral education, that's all we mean.
We mean, we want them to be aware that they are not unique consciousnesses,
which are little dictators of reality.
We want them to be aware that they are fishermen and Fisher women standing along
the long stream of life where many, many,
many have stood before where their place is unique but not specially privileged.
That's what we do.
And even if they look down at the grass and at the fish that those are cousins
did, those are cousins that those are distant. Great, great, great grandparents.
That I think has the virtue of being a genuinely and profoundly inspiring view
of how we got here and what we're doing here.
And also has the not small advantage of being true
[inaudible]
well, not everybody would agree with that. This is true. Whether that's alums,
you, Adam Gopnik wrote angels and ages.
It's a short book about Darwin Lincoln and Modern Life. Oh,
he put them together. Yes. He put, cause they were born on the exact same day.
Same Birthday. Okay. Uh, Deb Heilig,
when she wrote Charles and Emma and David Coleman wrote the reluctant, Mr
[inaudible]
radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
the corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation.
I'm right. I'm not asked what Sam, Robert Krulwich,
but I'm not rubbing the thank goodness I'm a blue Rod, and I remember Colin,
we'll see you in two weeks.